[Music]
you're no stranger to that we know as
far as winning Oscars and awards but
talk to me about fine clay land it being
dedicated to your actual nanny that had
to be a monumental task can you tell me
how she was the one it was the moment I
met her and she walked into my office I
knew it was her you know I'm I was doing
a film or I did a film about one of the
other of the people I love the most you
know it's a woman who raised me so the
moment that your leads are working I
instinctively I used it I didn't have to
question it or even think why I know
that you also dedicated this to your mom
and your grandmother but talk to me just
about being back in Mexico City to bring
back any flashback from your childhood
at all well the whole film was a long
flashback of my of my childhood it was a
whole process of the film was based upon
memories and I was not only recreating
moments but we were shooting them in the
in the places where they took place or
Reverend reproducing the spaces to the
inch
and also casting people that are
look-alikes to the original people more
than 40 years ago so it was kind of an
odd experience to be reliving those
moments your family seen the film yet I
mean you're recreating this I'm sure
that they have some memories that come
to mind yes if they have seen it they
you know they are touched by the movie
they've been very supportive with it all
of them they share with me memories
while I was in the process of doing it
and also they share personal objects
that they kept from that time yeah
they're in the film um you Lisa she just
told us last week that you're someone
that changed her life how has she
changed your life or has she welcomed
needs and you know Galit sister is the
heart of Roma it's a film that without
the presence of jalisa and the
performance of jalisa it wouldn't work
and this film in many ways in my life
has been a before-and-after
so yeah lease is very important now
hosts in my life in a few words what was
the reaction when you watch the final
cut I know there are a lot of emotions
for me I teared up throughout the film
is that scene-stealer to be too dark or
should I lighten it up a little bit
because you know it's very funny because
when you were you're you're finishing
your movie you're just focusing in in
all the little details and the technical
details because you know that ones that
you let it go is going to be like this
forever and the irony is that ones that
I finish a film might never see them
again but I tell you the first time is
the only time I've seen it with audience
that it was the Venice Film Festival I
had to sit and watch the whole thing
because the protocol and what I was
really surprised and it was very very
moving it was the main surplus of the
people
[Music]
[Applause]